it's been just over three weeks since
hurricane Ian we all remember him
devastated parts of Southwest Florida
but there are signs of progress in some
really hearted areas for instance a
damaged Sanibel Island Causeway reopened
to Residents yesterday two days ahead of
schedule but miles from the coast
Florida's Citrus crop was badly damaged
now this is a major setback for
agriculture the state's largest second
industry and if you drink juice and most
of us do you could see a price hike
Manuel bojorkas is in Florida
Manny where are you exactly in Florida
uh we are in Alturas Florida this is
part of the Citrus growing region here
that's right and uh so for context
painting the picture here Ian made
landfall about 90 miles from this area
but it was still a hurricane when it
came through this Grove so it stripped
the Trees of fruit that was soon to be
harvested knocked down other trees like
this one and some were so waterlogged
they may be ruined too
fruit hit the ground and washed away Ben
Krauss is a third generation Citrus
grower he walked through these Groves as
a two-year-old and says this is by far
the worst storm damage he's seen it
looks like a river went through here
yeah and it did and I mean you're
exactly right over two thousand acres he
estimates losing 40 to 50 percent of the
crop white sandy soil marks where it
flooded this is the kind of thing that
would put you out of business you know
half half your crop uh Gone Gone in a
night
there's nothing that you can really do
to prepare for something like that
Florida's Citrus grows across 375 000
Acres that sprawl over much of what
became Ian's path
one estimate puts losses to the state's
overall agricultural industry at more
than a billion and a half dollars up to
304 million from Citrus but as Growers
like Steve Johnson assess their losses
that figure could grow we don't know the
effects of the water on the root systems
and what it's done and so those are
things that are long lasting that may
not show up for six to eight months
Florida Growers were already struggling
with a tree disease called Citrus
Greening that left fruit smaller and
unusable they were starting to see
advances against the disease when Ian
hit this is not where you want to see
the oranges Shannon Shep is executive
director of the Florida Department of
citrus it's such a huge moment
um
we're standing in a place where tourists
don't usually think of in Florida
but this is a backbone of our state's
economy you've got truck dealers and
tire dealers and diners on the corner
and schools that are fed by the economy
driven by Agriculture and despite the
losses here Ben Crouse says he's driven
to keep the family business going as
tough as it might be at this point to
keep going
you feel like you have to I do and I've
got I've got a son that's two now and I
bring him through these same Groves and
uh I don't I don't want it to end on my
watch
as he and other Growers tried to recover
it is worth noting that nearly 90
percent of Florida oranges are turned
into juice so the losses here of course
raising concerns about a price hike a
possible one at the supermarket but that
largely depends on Supply from other
orange producing areas Tony
and there really is no replacement for a
glass of orange juice in the morning
Manny thank you very much something
tells me that that price hike is coming
but I really admire as devastating as it
is he still says he wants to continue
he's got a son yeah and I like what he
said I don't want it to happen on my
watch yeah I love that kind of every
generation is a caretaker for the next
you know trying to leave it we want to
pass it on in good condition yeah
exactly right and it's important because
people that are in this generational
transfer of their businesses their
livelihoods they depend on that for
their income yeah so we want to be a
sport it's true